aber ich kann ihnen sagen wie es
weitergeht nämlich ebenfalls mit einem
zusatzpunkte aufgesetzt wurde corona
selbsttests und das ist ja aktueller
denn je nach den entwicklungen der
letzten zwei drei tage
es ist ein antrag der fdp fraktion die
fordert schneller einfacher freier mit
corona selbst es zurück in die
normalität und das wünschen sie
natürlich alle
die bundeskanzlerin hat ja angedeutet
dass am dritten beraten wird und dann
möglichst schnell die selbsttests
eingeführt werden die fdp hatte am noch
ein paar andere vorschläge andere
ullmann
für die fdp ist die zeit der realität
ins auge zu schauen
unlängst besorgen bürgerinnen und bürger
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
schnelltest offensichtlich ganz legal da
sie selbst einer kooperation zur kunde
besitzen aber warum machen sie das
sicherlich nicht aus jux und dollerei
sondern aus verantwortung aus
verantwortung für die familie aus
verantwortung für den betrieb aus
verantwortung für die gesellschaft in
österreich sind bereits etwa 250
selbsttest anbieter auf den markt
vertreten
in deutschland sind seit gestern 3
erlaubt aber noch kein einziger auf dem
markt unser antrag selbst einen sicheren
rechtsrahmen der mitmenschen schnell
sich selbst testen können und wir geben
den menschen damit eine echte
perspektive in dieser pandemie krise die
freidemokraten wollen menschen
möglichkeit aus dem lot anbieten und
dazu dürfen wir gerne auf andere länder
blicken
das praxisbeispiele von ländern für
österreich machen sie uns bereits vor
dabei bietet sich da selbst heraus dass
einer von mehreren wichtigen bausteine
in der pandemie bekämpfung an
die vorteile liegen auf der hand doch
was macht die regierung für die
zulassungen müssen grundsätzlich
staatliche stellen benannte stellen
prüfungen und bewertungen
der konformitätsbewertung durchführen
und deren korrektheit nach einheitlichen
bewertungsmaßstäben bescheinigen
klingt kompliziert ist es auch dauert
etwa vier bis acht wochen natürlich darf
es bei der qualität keine abstriche
geben und hier steht auch hier nicht zu
debatte aber es geht auch anders
beispiel österreich österreich
entwickelte ein einfaches verfahren zum
inverkehrbringen von antigen
schnelltests zur selbstanwendung wenn
das konformitätsbewertungsverfahren noch
nicht durchgeführt wurde können die
hersteller mit einer selbstverpflichtung
bestätigen dass bei eigenanwendung ein
sicherheits und leistungsniveau erreicht
wird und dass die funktions und
einsatztauglichkeit für den geplanten
zweck gewährleistet ist mit einer
entsprechenden selbstverpflichtung
können die hersteller ihre selbst
vertreiben denn sie haben ja bereits
diese daten
wir wollen diesen weg gehen natürlich
müssen die so in verkehr gebrachten test
einschließt an schließlich gleich
anschließend entschuldigung ein
schnellstmögliches post hoc
zulassungsverfahren durchlaufen
wir wollen selbst fest für den
stufenplan zur eröffnung der
gesellschaftlichen lebens nutzen mit
einem nachweis eines negativen
testergebnis per digitaler hat können
wir grundrechte zurückgeben und unserem
land wieder eine perspektive geben so
ist gemeinsam mit den ländern zu prüfen
inwieweit vom lockdown betroffenen
öffentlichen und lebensfeindlichen
unternehmen wir privaten lebensbereiche
die restaurants hotels kultur
fahrenschon theater kinos sportanlagen
fitnesscenter usw
mit dem nachweis von negativen
testergebnis unter hygiene konzepten
wieder geöffnet bzw besucht werden
können gerne auch als 24 stunden tages
passt
geschwindigkeit mit garantie wird
qualitätsgarantie ist hier die
marschrichtung wir müssen auf die tube
drücken schneller einfacher freier
so hätten wir mit der korona selbsttests
die chance in die normalität
zurückzukommen
denn statt einen ankündigungsminister
mit einer langsamen nebel vaart wollen
wir eine politik der
verantwortungsvollen perspektive und
hoffnung geben
herzlichen dank andere uhr im atelier
antrag der fdp begründet täglich einen
selbst test pro person fordert die fdp
und das zumindest so lange bis genug
impfungen der nächste redner ist jetzt
stefan pischinger
er ist mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
schon seit beginn dieser pandemie lautet
unsere devise umfassend und gezielt
testen
deshalb haben wir unsere test
kapazitäten bereits im vergangenen
frühjahr schnell hochgefahren und
seitdem kontinuierlich ausgebaut denn
wir wissen testen gehört zu den
wichtigsten werkzeugen bei der
bekämpfung des krone virus mit den
antiken schnelltest können wir jetzt
auch ohne großen aufwand vor ort testen
und damit mögliche infektionsketten
zügig unterbrechen
besonders sinnvoll ist dass zb in
pflegeheimen medizinischen einrichtungen
oder gemeinschaftsunterkünften also
überall dort wo viele menschen auf engem
raum zusammenkommen
für die pflegeheime stellen wir dafür
seit dezember auch umfangreiche
finanzielle mittel zur verfügung und
zwar nicht nur für die tests fit sondern
auch für das fachpersonal bislang
waren jedoch solche antigen schnell dass
auf dem markt die gemäß ihrer zulassung
ausschließlich für den professionellen
gebrauch vorgesehen waren
gestern hat das bundesinstitut für
arzneimittel und medizinprodukte nun
aber auch die ersten drei sonderzulagen
für schnelltest zur eigenanwendung
erteilt damit ist jetzt ein umso
wichtiger die alltagstauglichkeit und
die leistungsfähigkeit dieser neuen
tests im blick zu behalten
zudem brauchen diese produkte zwingend
verständliche gebrauchshinweise die auf
die richtige anwendung aber auch auf die
limitationen hinweisen denn ein falsch
angewendete test bringt in der regel
erst einmal ein negatives ergebnis und
dessen sollten wir uns bewusst sein
vor lauter euphorie über die
schnelltests muss sich zudem gerade in
dieser situation erneut wird der
weiteren ausbreitung der neuen virus
mutationen warnen auch wenn jetzt die
ersten schnelltest zugelassen sind wir
werden in dieser situation auf absehbare
zeit keine kompletten lockerungen
umsetzen können länder wie
großbritannien und portugal standen im
vergangenen jahr genau an diesem punkt
und mit sehen dort beschlossene
lockerung hat sich die zahl der chor
ohne fälle binnen weniger wochen
vervielfacht
auch deutschland ist vor dieser gefahr
nicht gefeit meine damen und herren der
anteil der britischen mutante liegt
mittlerweile bereits bei über 30 wer auf
die studiendaten aus großbritannien
schaut sieht dass diese variante bis zu
50% ansteckender sein kann und mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit sogar schwere
krankheitsverläufe auslöst und ich sage
es ihnen noch mal
sobald diese gefährliche virus mutante
den wildtyp verdrängt hat und das kann
bereits in wenigen wochen der fall sein
dann werden die fallzahlen auch bei uns
wieder steigen jetzt vor allem auch um
gezielte massentests zu bauen kann
gefährlich sein
im vergleich zum pcr test sind
schnelltests zu dem insbesondere bei
asymptomatischen patienten deutlich
weniger empfindlich und je mehr menschen
wir damit ohne anlass testen desto
ungenauer wird das ergebnis aus meiner
sicht fahren wir besser damit gezielt zu
test nun nicht einfach ins blaue hinein
zum beispiel überall dort wo sich ältere
und kranke menschen aufhalten oder wo
eine ansteckung wahrscheinlich ist heldt
energiepolitiker gestalten sie eine
zwischenfalls kollegen und man ja
natürlich
vielen dank dass sie die frage zu lassen
sie sprachen gerade über die
unzuverlässigkeit des tests meinen sie
dass wir an die tester klassen sollten
würden sie jetzt sagen für schulen
beispielsweise den schülerinnen schüler
getestet werden ist das besser oder soll
es gleich sein lassen und ich trotzdem
in die schule schicken
wie sehen sie das weil sie haben jetzt
gerade ein plädoyer gegen dieses diese
testung gehalten und mich würde
interessieren wie ihre meinung oder
meinung der union ist diesbezüglich auch
diese schnelltests vielleicht doch
widersinnig sind also herr kollege
uhlmann ich habe deutlich gesagt dass
schnelltest ein wirkungsvolles mittel
sind aber kein allheilmittel
man muss deutlich darauf hinweisen dass
bei symptomatischen patienten der
schnelltest oft nicht sensibel genug ist
und wir können mit dem schnelltest nur
feststellen ob jemand hoch ansteckend
ist und deswegen müssen wir uns genau
überlegen wen wir testen und wenn wir
testen dann müssen wir sie regelmäßig
testen nämlich diese schnellstens eine
momentaufnahme und wie der professor
meyer hermann auch richtigerweise in der
vergangenheit schon mehrfach in den
medien gesagt hat dieser schnelltest
lässt nur eine aussage auf die letzten
12 bis 24 stunden zu und deswegen denke
ich dass man die noch mal genau eruieren
muss wo und wann und wie oft wir testen
und tests werden alleine aber kein
allheilmittel sein um die virus mutation
einzudämmen und massentest haben auch in
österreich haben auch in österreich
nicht dazu geführt dass wir uns komplett
aus zu löschen
[Applaus]
eine weiter im vergleich zum pc ältesten
städte es zudem insbesondere bei
symptomatischen patienten deutlich
weniger empfindlich und wie mehr
menschen wir damit ohne anlass testen
desto ungenauer wird das ergebnis
mittlerweile stehen uns die tests auch
in ausreichender zahl zur verfügung
deshalb bin ich nun der ist nun der
richtige zeitpunkt die anwendung des
schnellzugs auf weitere bereiche
auszudehnen zb zur täglichen testung in
kitas und schulen mit den regelmäßigen
tests können wir zwar nicht alle
infizierten sofort erkennen aber
zumindest ein großteil derjenigen die
bereits hoch ansteckend sind
hier sind wir jetzt klar im vorteil zum
vergangenen jahr also uns noch nicht
ausreichende tests zur verfügung standen
und diesen vorteil sollten wir nun
nutzen
hier sind natürlich gilt in der jetzigen
situation ein negativer test ist nur
eine momentaufnahme und entbindet uns
nicht von den einhaltung der korona
maßnahmen gezielte testungen auf das
coroner virus sind ein wesentlicher
baustein in der eindämmung der pandemie
aber sie werden eben gerade nicht zu
einer signifikanten absenkung der
fallzahlen führen können
aus unser weg aus der pandemie bleibt
weiterhin impfungen und ich möchte in
diesem zusammenhang noch einmal betont
auch wenn andere länder hier eine
abweichende strategie fahren bei uns
besteht weiterhin der individuelle
vollständige schutz des einzelnen im
vordergrund
sobald uns ausreichende impfungen zur
verfügung stehen können wir die impfung
auch in die hände der niedergelassenen
ärzte geben und dann werden sich die
täglichen im kapazitäten noch einmal
vervielfachen
bis dahin müssen wir uns aber gedulden
schnelltest können uns über die
kommenden monate hinweg helfen und sie
werden auch leben retten aber bitte
lassen sie sich nicht dazu verleiten
darin eine lösung für diese krise zu
sehen
es handelt sich um ein gutes werkzeug
nicht weniger aber auch nicht mehr so
lange wir uns kontakte und unsere
mobilität weiterhin einschränken
wird das virus auch weniger gelegenheit
vor finden sich zu verbreiten und das
ist es worauf es jetzt wirklich ankommt
vielen dank stefan pischinger war das
von der cdu/csu man muss ihn mal loben
er ist ganz kurzfristig eingesprungen
denn eigentlich sollte an dieser stelle
georgen nüßlein der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
sprechen
er wurde aber vorhin zurückgezogen denn
sie haben es mitbekommen die
durchsuchung beim abgeordneten diese
betrifft ihn seine immunität aufgehoben
worden
georg nüßlein es muss die
unschuldsvermutung gelten solange nichts
anderes bewiesen ist aber ihm wird
vorgeworfen und spionage verdacht wegen
weitergabe von bundestags grundrissen an
russland man kann es kaum glauben
nächster redner jetzt hier eine debatte
der fische fangen bergen für die afg
test wie auch selbst test gelten nicht
als sicher aussagefähige befunden
ein antikörper schnell das kann negativ
ausfallen während der getestete personen
infektions ist das erste problem oder
ein antikörper schnelltest kann durch
eine frühere infektion mit einem anderen
corona virus positiver ausfallen
dabei ist unklar ob diese schnelltests
beziehungsweise selbst setzt hier
trennscharf analysieren
ein schnelltest kann ein pc attest nicht
ersetzen sondern ein positiver muss
durch einen pcr test überprüft werden
die fdp im amt doch selbst auch noch mal
festgestellt
und drinnen sind der öffentlichen
anhörung zu dem fdp-antrag ja hieß
praxistaugliche test regieren 28 oktober
erklärte der sachverständige professor
martin exner präsident der deutschen
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene wie
unsicher und ungenau
die präventive testung eines symptomlose
mittels an die gegen schnell fest ist
nur zu 50 prozent erhält man ein
ergebnis welches mit dem pcr test an
übereinstimmt also meine damen und
herren die fdp die tägliche selbst
leistung so habe ich das zumindest
herausgelesen also 60 millionen wären
das ungefähr im lande und der täglich
im monat auf 1,8 milliarden test ich das
richtig gerechnet habe
wie sollen die herkommen soll die
bezahlen wäre für mich die frage meine
damen und herren schon die korona waren
app fürs smartphone hat sich nicht
bewährt und wird schon viel zu wenig
menschen benutzt trotzdem will die fdp
mit ihrem antrag darauf aufbauen
problematisch aus meiner sicht auch dass
es viele menschen gibt entweder gar kein
smartphone nutzen besitzen oder in der
lage sind sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
was ist mit dieser gruppe erreichen sie
damit nicht ungeachtet dieser mail
sollen dieser schlüssel für den
friseurbesuch zum eintritt für
veranstaltungen oder der
restaurantbesuch werden
der fcb über die sogenannte ergänzte
corona web-app meldungen an die
gesundheitsämter einreichen das
interessant sollen die testergebnisse
aus dem 6 welchen er noch wesentlich
unsicherer ist als der pcr test gemeldet
werden obwohl diese eine überprüfung
durch einen pc es dann noch bedarf also
die ganz neu für mich
je mehr getestet wird auch das ist
gestern schon mal angesprochen worden um
so mehr positive ergebnis erhält man und
wohl sich an der situation nichts ändert
die gefahr besteht hierbei dass die
zahlreichen positiven ergebnissen
höherer effizienz werte und damit seinem
blog führen können das ist das große
problem versicherte er
meine damen und herren vergleichbar ist
die pflicht zugestellt ist also unserer
sicht mit einem internet im 2 dies wird
von der afg das wissen sie entschieden
abgelehnt der rat von grund und
freiheitsrechten darf nicht an eine
bedingung geknüpft werden
meine damen und herren
selbst es können sinnvoll sein keine
frage zum beispiel vor einem geplanten
besuch von bei risikogruppen die wir
kennen und auch für menschen die
medizinischen berufen arbeiten aber dies
muss immer freiwillig und
eigenverantwortlich erfolgen
häufige regelmäßig ist von symptomen
losen gesunden mit einem ungenauen und
nicht sonderlich aussage fäden ergebnis
führen in falsch positiven fall sei eine
unnötige verunsicherung voreiliger
selbstisolation eine mögliche
überprüfung mit der spitze erst test
durch einen arzt sowieso erforderlich
was ist mit der psychologische wirkung
die der ständigen hab-acht-stellung okay
was passiert mir ja was ist schon wieder
los also ihr gesetzlicher ständig in
irgend einer gefahrensituation meine
damen und herren ich halte das für
problematisch
von seinem büro erklärte europa general
sagte er hinterher
hans henry kluge die caron ab an dem die
dinge trotz noch sehr geringer im cody
ihrem ende entgegen und überhaupt nicht
aufgegriffen die aussage von ihnen der
unter anderem für den erotischen biologe
klaus stöhr erklärt schon vor wochen
dass eine dritte welle und eine stark
ansteigende zahl von mutationen der
anfang vom ende einer pandemie bedeuten
und diese erfahrungsgemäß danach in der
ausbreitung stark rückläufig ist diese
einschätzung hat das ja nicht von mir
diese einschätzung teilen angefahren
wenn die ziele ebenso kann man sich doch
mal mit auseinandersetzen alleinige
ausrichtung eine flächendeckende lizenz
wäre hält er für illusorisch frankfurter
rundschau am fenster oder selbst versatz
der dauer lockten vor allem die
feststellung der dämlichen lage
nationale tat weisen müssen beendet
werden aber ohne testung und
smartphone-apps grundrechte freiheit und
eigenverantwortung müssen wir alle
lieber gewährt werden
vielen dank jetzt noch mal meine
ungläubigkeit von hinten war nicht
unberechtigt die weitergabe von
bundestags grundrissen an russland wird
einem mitarbeiter einer firma
vorgeworfen die für den das parlament
tätig ist
dennoch ist offensichtlich auch von
georg nüßlein offensichtlich die
immunität aufgehoben worden
der grund ist im moment mir zumindest
nicht bekannt aber das andere hätte mich
jetzt auch schon extrem gewundert also
nochmal um es klarzustellen die
weitergabe von bundestags grundrissen an
russland wird nicht hemmnis land
vorgeworfen sondern eine mitarbeiter
einer externen firma so viel zeit muss
sein hillemacher ist jetzt für die spd
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist gut die nachricht von gestern ist
euphorisch und das drei eigentums
zugelassen werden bietet tatsächlich den
einstieg in die normalität und hat
allerdings auch zur folge dass es eine
hohe erwartungshaltung der bevölkerung
gibt zu sagen wir wollen eine
perspektive aus dem schacht bieten und
haben und wir wollen dass wir wieder
eine perspektive in die normalität
hinein haben und daher braucht man jetzt
vor allen dingen eine genauer
betrachtungsweise
was können denn diese eigentlich
überhaupt leisten und was können diese
eigenen test leisten damit wir einfach
auch infektionsketten durchbrechen
können
und klar sagen können neben allen an
dinge die wir als maßnahmen miteinander
vereinbart haben ist der eigenen test
etwas was als ergänzung kostenlos
angeboten werden muss kostenlos
und ich sage mal dieser public health
ansatz den wir da fahren ist einer den
man aber auch in ein konzept gießen muss
der aber auch da sein muss und präsent
sein muss nicht nur populistisch als wir
geben das in jedem discounter und jeder
kann sich bedienen sondern auch mit
einem konzept hinter lebt nach dem motto
was muss ich wenn machen was muss ich
machen wenn mein test positiv ist
was kann ich tun wenn mein test negativ
ist und insbesondere darauf hinweisen
wenn mein test negativ ist entbindet
mich das nicht von meiner verantwortung
für den nächsten und für mich wenn
meinte es positiv ist und da schaue ich
schon auf die regierungsbank dann muss
klar sein
erstens an wen muss ich mich wenden
zweitens wo kann ich den pc es ganz
schnell nachmachen
drittens wo sind die leute die mich da
unterstützen in meiner isolation
das bringt nicht zu einem zweiten punkt
nämlich der logistik was kann nicht
einsetzen
reicht das beim aldi an der kasse
irgendwie ein körbchen hinzustellen nein
natürlich nicht sondern ich muss in die
schulen gehen und womöglich auch den
schulen sagen jetzt einen schüler
schülerinnen
einen schülerausweis dann gehen die in
die apotheke holen sich eine
wochenration eigentlich ab oder ich sage
dem unternehmen sagen bitte da im
arbeitnehmer wenn deine arbeitnehmerin
hier du kriegst einen ausweis du bist
hast eine präsenzpflicht in
beschäftigung gehen die apotheke und die
apotheker müssen natürlich wissen was
wie kann ich abrechnen
das sind logistische fragen die muss man
klären bevor man der bevölkerung zu hohe
erwartungen mache ich möchte nicht
erleben dass wir wieder eine situation
haben wenn es nämlich darum geht jetzt
die eigenen test so zu implementieren
das ist auch auf vertrauen bei der
bevölkerung fußen kann dass ich doch der
wichtige punkt also unternehmen der
logistik und dem konzept natürlich auch
eine priorisierung und ich glaube es ist
fast unstrittig mit kindern und
jugendlichen zu beginnen das macht sinn
und die müssen das morgens neben ihrer
zahnbürste liegen haben und die eltern
müssen da dabei sein und bei kleinen
kindern müssen die eltern die eigentlich
bekommen
dieses braucht aber eine hohe test
kapazität und da frage ich den minister
ist sichergestellt dass wir genügend
test haben das muss man machen
ich möchte nicht dass sage ich noch mal
dass diese wichtige ergänzung lisa
public health ansatz dadurch zerstört
wird dass wir das politisch nicht
vorausblickend planen und organisieren
das möchte ich nicht und dann ist es
fast das wichtigste dass wir nämlich
eine kampagne eine aufklärungskampagne
machen mehrsprachig natürlich
auch barrierefrei das klar ist das muss
in jedem bahnhof hängen wie nutze ich
die das klar ist dass muss jeder runter
deklinieren können
in klarer sprache und es muss die
sicherheit sein
wenn ich womöglich deine telefonnummer
habe die kann ich auch erreichen da bin
ich nicht in irgendwelchen
warteschleifen drehen so und da frage
ich das ministerium dem minister ist da
vorausschauend daran gedacht ist da
vorausschauend auch alles organisiert
ich weiß was sie fragen wollen deswegen
gestatte ich mir diese frage nicht
zuzulassen ist da vorausschauend dran
gedacht
und man habe jetzt gesagt sie lassen die
zwischenfrage zu nein
und vor allen dingen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen so viele optionen haben wir
nicht mehr
wir haben nicht mehr die option noch mal
jetzt nachdem die zahlen wieder leicht
steigen wir die hoffnung nach
weihnachten hatten wir haben in sie denn
zahlen die einfach auch die marke 35
irgendwann erreichen
nachdem diese hoffnung so einfach nicht
erfüllt wird brauchen wir eine
perspektive und die dürfen wir uns
selber nicht kaputt machen
dadurch dass wir es politisch nicht
hinkriegen genau diese dinge so auf die
reihe zu kriegen in den fünf punkten die
ich das gerade gesagt habe vielen dank
so meine damen und herren jetzt noch ein
letztes mal zur georg nüßlein dessen
immunität heute aufgehoben wurde der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu
bislang soll für eine sechsstellige
provision einen massenhersteller an die
bundesregierung und an die bayrische
bundesregierung auch vermittelt haben
soweit der vorwurf gegen den csu
abgeordneten achim keßler jetzt in der
debatte für die linksfraktion dieser
rede fahrt man sich ja fast auch die spd
noch in der regierung ist oder nicht
mehr aber sei es drum schnelltests
durchgeführt im gesundheitsdienst in
arztpraxen und apotheken aber auch als
selbst fest für zu hause sind ein
wichtiger bestandteil ich glaube da sind
wir uns einig wichtiges mittel zur
bekämpfung der pandemie
die linke hat schon seit dem sommer
gefordert dass schnelltests
flächendeckend zur verfügung stehen
müssen und zwar kostenlos und meine
damen und herren beharrlichkeit zahlt
sich aus wir freuen uns sehr wenn unsere
forderung jetzt tatsächlich eine
mehrheit bekommt aber der
gesundheitsminister hat dieses thema
monate lang verschlafen
für die impfungen wurden wie hunderte
millionen euro ausgegeben für die
beschaffung der masken hat der bund
milliarden euro in die hand genommen
aber bei schnelltests insbesondere bei
schnelltests in eigene anwendungen ist
nichts passiert das rächt sich jetzt
denn angesichts des mangels an
impfstoffen angesichts der mutation die
sich wesentlich schneller verbreiten
gibt es gar keine andere möglichkeit
lockerungen von freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen herbeizuführen als durch
massenhafte schnelltests wie immer in
dieser pandemie fährt die
bundesregierung nur auf sicht angesichts
dieser katastrophe katastrophalen für
den verfolgung für die menschen ist das
wirklich unverzeihlich und herr minister
sogar ohne geld und ohne staatliche
einkaufs programme hätten sie etwas
machen können
es hat sich ja schon geholfen wenn sie
frühzeitig die medizinprodukte abgabe
verordnung so geändert hätten das nicht
nur ärzte sondern auch alle anderen die
schnelltests kaufen können das wäre ein
anreiz gewesen die tests zur
selbstanwendung schnell zu entwickeln
das hätten sie schon im letzten sommer
machen können als wir das gefordert
haben es passiert ist es jetzt erst am
dritten februar 2021
diese fortgesetzte weigerung
vorausschauend und da kann ich der
kollegin mattheis nur zustimmen
vorausschauend maßnahmen vorzubereiten
wirft die frage auf ob sie in der
pandemie überhaupt regierungsfähig sind
ich freue mich dass ich zuerst die spd
und dann auch der gesundheitsminister
unsere forderungen angeschlossen haben
schnell test kostenlos anzubieten
das war aber auch wirklich höchste zeit
denn es darf nicht sein dass die
möglichkeit sich testen zu lassen vom
geldbeutel abhängt und ich traue es den
meisten menschen zu dass sie auch mit
einem privat durchgeführten test mit
einem positiven ergebnis
verantwortungsvoll umgehen werden
denn gerade menschen die sich privat
selbst testen beweisen dass ihnen die
panini dass ihnen das virus nicht egal
sind
sie beweisen rücksicht sie beweisen
verantwortungsbewusstsein sie beweisen
solidarität und genau darin will die
linke die menschen bestärken und
unterstützen verstand ich habe mich
persönlich wirklich sehr gefreut als die
kostenlose schnelltest für den ersten
märz angekündigt haben
umso größer jetzt die enttäuschung dass
weitere aufschieben von kostenlosen
schnelltest durch die bundesregierung
versteht wirklich niemand mehr
9 milliarden euro zusagen für die
lufthansa das geht ruckzuck das ist gar
kein problem aber die einführung
kostenloser schnelltest erfolgt erst
nach monaten öffentlicher debatte und
jetzt verschieben sie die einführungen
nochmal und dabei bräuchten wir die
schnelltests so dringend um die zeit zu
überbrücken bis wir endlich genug
impfstoffe haben damit alle geimpft
werden können
dieses total versagen der
bundesregierung bei der bekämpfung der
pandemie muss jetzt wirklich ein ende
haben auch zu hause in der schule oder
am arbeitsplatz oder perspektivisch vor
einem theater oder kinobesuch
schnelltest können erheblich dazu
beitragen die verbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen und infektionskette zu
unterbrechen
die bundesregierung muss endlich alle
möglichkeiten ergreifen um die panini
weltweit zu
7 und freiheits einschränkungen so
schnell wie möglich wieder zu beenden
dazu gehört habe oft darüber geredet
hier die freigabe der impfstoff patente
damit weltweit impfstoffe produziert
werden können dazu gehört eine test
strategie die auch kostenlose
schnelltests für alle ermöglicht dass es
bisher versäumt wurde allen menschen zb
mit kundenkontakt kassiererinnen
zustellern schnelltests zur verfügung zu
stellen ist unverzeihlich
der schutz am arbeitsplatz muss endlich
verbindlich geregelt und mit kontrollen
abgesichert werden aber wenn ich zum
beispiel mit nein es ist nicht die sache
der betriebe sondern dass die sache
dieser regierung arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer zu schützen
aber wenn ich zum beispiel mit
lehrerinnen und lehrern sprechen dann
höre ich dass bei vielen noch immer
keinen schnelltest durchgeführt werden
das wäre aber dringend notwendig wenn
wir jetzt die schulen wieder öffnen
wollen ähnliches gilt für erzieherinnen
und erzieher und es gilt auch für wird
gefährdete personengruppen zb in
sammelunterkünften aber auch für
menschen mit behinderung und mit selbst
gewählt organisierten pflege modellen
kommen sie endlich ihrer verantwortung
nach eine umfassende versorgung mit
kostenlosen schnelltest zu gewährleisten
und dazu meine damen und herren gehört
auch die gesundheitsämter und die
kommunen personell und finanziell so
auszustatten dass sie die bürgerinnen
und bürger in der pandemie umfassend
begleiten und beraten können
auch und gerade im zusammenhang mit den
schnelltests zu hause
der antrag der fdp
der antrag der fdp hat das ziel die
zulassung von schnelltests zu
beschleunigen so lohnenswert dieses ziel
ist so verantwortungslos ist der
vorgeschlagene der wirt der vorschlagen
den weg wir sind von der fdp einiges
gewöhnt aber in dieser stelle stockt
einem wirklich der atmung die offizielle
zulassung der schnell testen
ich zitiere eine einfache und
unbürokratische selbstverpflichtung des
herstellers zu ersetzen offenbart dass
es ihnen gar nicht um den schutz der
menschen geht sondern es geht ihm
schlicht und ergreifend um
wirtschaftsförderung ich bin mir ganz
ganz sicher dass die spenden aus der
pharmaindustrie für den
bundestagswahlkampf der fdp kräftig
sprudeln wird die linke jedenfalls lehnt
diesen unverantwortlichen unfug ab
bedanke mich ihre aufmerksamkeit denn so
uhlmann hatte sich noch gemeldet kern
aber nicht mehr zu wort mal sehen ob er
jetzt noch kurz dazwischen reden davon
dürfte
nein es gibt weiterhin der normalen
rädern reihenfolge mit janosch dahmen
von den bündnisgrünen er ist mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss der präsident werde
kolleginnen kollegen es ist kein
geheimnis dass testen und tracing neben
den kontakt beschränkungen und dem
impfen zu den wirksamsten instrumenten
in der bekämpfung des saas koch 2 virus
gehören was aber bis heute ein geheimnis
der bundesregierung bleibt ist die
konkrete ausgestaltung ihrer nationalen
test strategie im letzten sommer hatte
der bundesgesundheitsminister eine
nationale selbst strategie angekündigt
aber statt strategie nehme ich in den
letzten tagen vor allem kakophonie beim
thema testen und schnell testen von der
bundesregierung war das muss ein ende
haben
es ist doch nur noch verwirrt wenn
einerseits den bürgerinnen und bürgern
gesagt werden
testen ist so wichtig und wir auf der
anderen seite einfach so den tag der
zulassung der einführung kostenloser und
schneller wirksamer schnelltests
verschieben wann wird das passieren die
wird das sein wann wird das greifen das
kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein
wir reden hier um menschenleben und
[Applaus]
strategie liebe kolleginnen kollegen
strategie heißt planung und in der
planung der test strategie gibt es doch
erhebliche mängel
da wäre erstens das zulassungsverfahren
das ziemlich chaotisch abläuft erst hat
das bundesinstitut für arzneimittel
und medizinprodukte sämtliche
schnelltests die bereits europäische mit
einem ce kennzeichen zugelassen waren
ungeprüft auf eine zugelassene test
liste gesetzt um sie dann erst im
nachhinein selbst noch einmal zu
validieren und mitunter auch wieder test
von der liste zu streichen
bei den schnelltest zur selbstanwendung
dann genau das gegenteil
da dauert die zulassung nun viel zu
lange und es werden immer neue teils
bürokratische hürden aufgebaut
die selbsttests in den verruf bringen
und die test genauigkeit in frage
stellen
ich will noch einmal klarstellen weil
hier gerade auch gestern in der debatte
der eindruck erweckt würde wurde wir
grünen würden uns dafür aussprechen
ungenau oder unsichere schnelltest in
den umlauf bringen zu wollen
das gegenteil ist der fall die gestern
zugelassenen schnelltest zur
selbstanwendung sind vom
paul-ehrlich-institut seit anfang
dezember validiert und als zuverlässig
bestätigt und wir haben es in zwei
monaten nicht geschafft diese tests zur
selbstanwendung den menschen als
sicherheitsmaßnahme zur verfügung zu
stellen es kann doch nicht wahr sein
zwei monate in dem fast 20.000 menschen
gestorben sind und wir schauen an dieser
stelle nur zu das dauert zu lange hier
waren wir zu langsam zu spät und zu
langsam und zu spät reist in der
pandemie der ausbreitung des virus
hinterherzurennen anstatt endlich vor
die lage zu kommen
das zweite problem der test strategie
sind die produktionskapazitäten
produktionskapazitäten hängen
unmittelbar mit der nachfrage zusammen
und was mich ratlos macht ist dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister den
produzenten von schnell test bis heute
keine realistische bedarf einschätzung
und nicht die nötigen abnahmegarantien
geliefert hat liebe kolleginnen kollegen
nochmals eine strategie bedeutet planung
und bei den schnelltest brauchen die
produzenten planbarkeit damit sie
liefern können hier sind wir nicht nur
zu langsam und zu spät hier haben wir
dann am ende auch noch zu wenig tests
die wir dringend bräuchten krise heißt
kümmern und heißt sich nicht auf den
markt einfach zu verlassen
das dritte problem der test strategie
und das ärgert mich am meisten ist der
mangelnde wille der bundesregierung die
schnelltests zur selbstanwendung
als wirklichen game changer in der
pandemie bekämpfung einzusetzen
der gesundheitsminister will stattdessen
schnelltests in erster linie in
apotheken arztpraxen oder privaten test
centern durchführen lassen
wir werden das große potenzial der
schnelltest aber nur dann ausschöpfen
können wenn wir die hürden für die
durchführung von schnelltests so niedrig
wie möglich halten und das heißt
menschen müssen spontan in ihrem alltag
auf dem weg zur schule auf dem weg zu
einem treffen in einem termin oder zur
großmutter einen schnelltest
selbstständig durchführen können was wir
den menschen nicht zumuten können ist
jeden tag 30 oder 40 minuten bei einem
privaten test center in der schlange zu
stehen um einen schnelltests zu machen
mit den selbst test geben wir den
menschen handlungsfähigkeit in der krise
zurück wir machen sie zu aktiven
akteuren im kampf gegen dieses virus und
das brauchen wir jetzt ich sage auch als
arzt ganz deutlich die selbst testen
sind zuverlässig die selbst test sind
kostengünstig die selbst test binden
kein fachpersonal dass wir an anderer
stelle der pandemie bekämpfung im moment
viel dringender brauchen deshalb
appelliere ich an die bundesregierung
vertrauen sie unseren bürgern und
bürgern die können sich zuverlässig
selbst testen
geben sie jeder bürgerin und jeden
bürger jede woche zwei kostenlose selbst
test- und wir führen damit mehr
sicherheit in einer schwierigen phase
der pandemie ein und schaffen vertrauen
was wir dringend in der pandemie
bekämpfung brauchen erstarren lassen sie
uns hier motto testen testen testen mit
hilfe der bürgerinnen und bürger endlich
in die tat umsetzen und deshalb sage ich
sage ich hier an dieser stelle
wir müssen endlich zu einem prozedere
kommt selbst testen selbst testen selbst
testen denn eine sache liebe kollegen
kollegen muss uns doch klar sein wenn
jetzt die schulen öffnen und bald die
friseure dann müssen wir den menschen
ein sicherheits geländer gegen die
gefahr der ansteckung bauen und diese
sicherheits geländer sollte meines
erachtens mindestens aus drei elementen
bestehen den schnelltest zur
selbstanwendung den sicheren sozial
vertretenden flächendeckenden
medizinischen masken bzw ffp zwei masken
und einer funktionierenden kontakt
nachverfolgung einschließlich cluster
erkennung mit hilfe der krone war nett
wenn das öffentliche leben
an manchen stellen wieder losgeht dann
können wir uns kein zu spät zu langsam
zu wenig mehr leisten zeit ist der
kritische faktor in dieser pandemie
bekämpfung und hier sollten wir endlich
verantwortung übernehmen und für alle
menschen vernünftige lösungen schaffen
ein letztes wort noch zum fdp-antrag
herr kollege und ich wundere mich schon
sehr sie haben gerade aus ihren reihen
als wir vor vier wochen dieses thema
hier ins parlament eingebracht haben
ganz groß bericht gesagt die grünen
würden unverantwortliche
zulassungsverfahren befeuern und jetzt
legen sie einen vorschlag vor den wir
vor vier wochen in der phase der
pandemie wo klar war dass wir schnell
test zur selbstanwendung brauchen
ich muss ihnen ehrlicherweise sagen ich
hätte mir damals mehr unterstützung
gewünscht im kern bin ich aber froh dass
sie da unserem vorgehen sich anschließen
und jetzt hier im parlament
offensichtlich von verschiedenen stimmen
endlich der einsatz von schnelltests
gefordert wird vielen dank janosch
dahmen war das für die bündnisgrünen der
bundestag debattiert über den antrag der
fdp corona selbst des schneller
einfacher freier die bundeskanzlerin hat
bereits angedeutet dass am dritten märz
die sich nicht erst eine wichtige rolle
bei der eröffnungs strategiespielen
werden die dann hoffentlich mal
beschlossen wird der nächste redner hier
im parlament rudolf henke ist mitglied
im gesundheitsausschuss und
ehrenvorsitzender des marburger bundes
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren ich glaube wir müssen
mal wieder acht geben dass wir nicht ein
thema und seinen stellenwert und seine
bedeutung hier im parteipolitischen
möglicherweise auch durch nahende wahlen
beförderten konflikt zu reden
und ich will einfach dieses frei testen
der schnelltests einordnen
also sozusagen als arzt empfehle ich die
aussage die sind alle sicher das ist
eben erst erwiesen wenn es für die
bestimmte testklasse auch erwiesen ist
und deswegen ist natürlich auch ein
verfahren notwendig bei dem geprüft wird
ob es eine erfolg der ce kennzeichnung
für die professionelle anwendung gibt
bei dem geprüft wird ob das unternehmen
antrag bei einer benannten stelle zur
einbindung im rahmen eines
konformitätsbewertungsverfahren gestellt
hat wenn das nämlich nicht der fall wäre
wäre die situation die eintritt eine
ketten sonder zulassung das kann nicht
unser interesse sein
also muss nur bereits erfolgte positive
evaluierung durch das bei vorliegen
damit dass die farm entscheiden kann und
dann kann der nachweis des erfüllen
der speziell für die laien anwendung
spezifizierten grundlegenden
anforderungen aus der entsprechenden
eu-richtlinie stattfinden und für die
prüfung dieser anforderungen unter den
punkten 61 des anhangs der vdd muss auch
eine leyen studie vorliegen
und deswegen dauert es ein stück zeit
und ich finde wir sollten uns auch
gemeinsam dazu bekennen dass krise hin
krise her natürlich die
qualitätsanforderungen an
medizinprodukte nicht jetzt einfach alle
fahren gelassen wird und das schließt
dann auch
dass ich ja verständnis dafür habe dass
die fdp guckt kann man es denn
beschleunigen
und da sagen sie ja und zitieren die
niederländer entschuldigung die
österreichischen freunde und sagen dann
man kann dort durch eine
selbstverpflichtung des herstellers
bestätigen dass bei eigenanwendung ein
sicherheits und leistungsniveau erreicht
wird ja was heißt denn das wort dass da
ein sicherheits und leistungsniveau
erreicht wird ein sicherheits und
leistungsniveau wird immer erreicht bei
jeder beliebigen selbstbestätigung wird
ein sicherheits und leistungsniveau
erreicht welches ist doch entscheidend
und dann sagen sie der hersteller sollen
bestätigen dass die
funktionstauglichkeit und die
einsatztauglichkeit für den geplanten
zweck gewährleistet ist ja gerne wenn
man dem hersteller vertrauen kann wir
werden aber eine solche vielzahl an
herstellern haben die die produkte in
den markt zu drücken versuchen werden
dass wir das gleiche problem wieder
erleben werden wie wir es ja bei den
masken erlebt haben als wir die masken
aus aller welt bestellt haben und dann
hat man jens spahn vorgeworfen dass er
mit einer schere hingegangen ist sie
zerschnitten hat sie sich angeguckt hat
geprüft hat ob sie fünf tagen haben und
sich geweigert hat die zu bezahlen die
keine fünf funktions doppeln lagen
hatten so muss man das bei den
schnelltest auch machen wenn wir das so
nicht mehr hinter gestalten sie eine
zwischenfrage dazu android man für die
fdp
kommt das wort herr kollege hängte danke
dass sie die frage zu lassen
sie sprechen ja gerade österreich an ist
ihnen eigentlich bewusst dass die
schnelltest in österreich die zur
selbstanwendung zugelassen sind auch mit
der selbstverpflichtung aller eine ce
zertifizierung haben müssen entspricht
den daten vorliegen dann würde mich
immer wenn sie das wissen wäre jetzt
ihre argumentation endlich fehlgeleitet
denn die daten sind ja da oder trauen
sie diesen daten den firmen nicht zu
dass sie diese daten richtig erhoben
haben ihr kollege ullmann die
ce-kennzeichnung für die professionellen
sendung stellt sicher dass der
hersteller mit den einschlägigen
gesetzlichen und normativen vorgaben für
tests vertraut ist und das entsprechende
leistungsnachweise erfolgt sind erstellt
überhaupt noch nicht sicher dass etwa
eine leyen studie vorliegt und insofern
die ce anwendung ja die ist eine
wichtige und wesentliche voraussetzung
um dinge in den markt zu bringen
aber natürlich sind an
sicherheitsrelevante medizinprodukte
selbstverständlich weitere anforderungen
zu stellen und zu sagen ce
zertifizierung und damit ist es dann gut
das reicht jedenfalls aus unserer
auffassung nicht insbesondere wenn so
relevante entscheidungen wie die die sie
in aussicht gestellt haben nämlich die
frage ob man bestimmte kinos theater
restaurants den eigenen onkel ein
fußballspiel besuchen kann wenn das
daran geknüpft wird dann ist das meines
erachtens zu wenig und nun noch ein wort
zu der frage welche aussagekraft haben
denn jetzt dieses antigen tests nicht
antikörpertest wie eben mal gesagt
bundes antigen tests und da will ich aus
dem epidemiologischen bulletin von heute
zitieren dass das rkw herausgibt gerade
bei der anwendung von antigen tests
durch laien ist es essentiell dass der
anwender das testergebnis richtig
interpretieren und sachgerechte
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen kann
ein positives
ergebnis stellt zunächst einen verdacht
auf eine saas koch 2 infektion da es ist
jedoch noch keine diagnose die diagnose
kommt erst durch den nachfolgenden pcr
test und die ärztliche beurteilung und
einem positiven antigen testergebnis
folgen natürlich dann hohe anforderungen
an das daraus resultierende selbst
verantwortliche handeln denn es ist
erforderlich dass sich die positiv
getestete person in absonderung begibt
und sich telefonisch mit dem hausarzt
oder einem geeigneten testzentrum in
verbindung setzt der dann die pcr
testung in die wege leistet und es ist
ein nicht richtig verstandene aspekt
wenn man glaubt dass man sich mit einem
negativen schnelltests egal ob er jetzt
in der unterstützung durch profis oder
in dem selbst dessen stadt wendet dass
man sich damit frei testen kann
weitesten kann man sich nicht weil es
eine momentaufnahme für ganz kurze zeit
ist einen tag würde ich sagen manche
sagen sogar sechs bis sieben oder acht
stunden
und das ist nicht aussagefähig dafür
dass man jetzt in den nächsten tagen
praktisch nicht ansteckend ist zu dem
zeitpunkt wo der test positiv ausfällt
ist mit hoher sicherheit klar dass man
jetzt andere anstecken kann und diese
beratung muss man natürlich auch in
irgendeiner weise sicherstellen weil der
eindruck den sie mit dem titel ihres
antrags erwecken
jannis und andere die regelung zum
schluss ganz andere erwartungen weckt
schneller einfacher freier mit corona
selbsttests zurück in die normalität
gemacht dass der german mut nicht zu
viel von frühlings freude beeinträchtigt
wird aber ich wünsche ihnen trotzdem ein
schönes früh rohstoff ist ja bekannt wir
haben verstanden auf die frau kollegen
zu schauen
die ganze zeit versucht eine frage zu
stehen aber es gut ich bin ja auch über
die zeit
also ein bisschen lästig geworden ich
wünsche ihnen einen schönen frühling
vielen dank
henke auch für die branche oder finke
war das mit dem osterfest etwas verfrüht
aber die ausführung waren interessant
noch mal die unions positionen auch die
des bundesgesundheitsministers
darzulegen dass solche tests auch die
anforderungen erfüllen müssen und
natürlich getestet sein müssen bevor sie
allen zugänglich gemacht werden können
die fdp ist ja in ihrem kroner
selbsttest antrag der meinung dass diese
tests sofort um so schnell wie möglich
auch wenn nicht alle prüfungen erfolgt
sind auf den markt gebracht werden
sollten paul viktor portal für die afg
hat jetzt das wort und die maske tragen
nun da versteht ihr da was anderes
darunter
der präsident meine damen und herren
corona selbst test gelten als
möglichkeit das land aus dem tal zu
führen
die intention ist absolut zu begrüßen
doch wie soll das in der realität
aussehen und ist es mit dem schnelltest
getan natürlich nicht ob es das seriös
sein
das reale infektionsgeschehen in der
bevölkerung differenziert hat zu bilden
und sich nicht fanatisch an willkürliche
inzidenz werte zu klammern
es ist bekannt dass dieser selbst in
größen großen mengen falsch positive und
negative resultate produziert werden
das heißt sie sind ungenau was ist die
konsequenz wenn alle anfangen sich wie
verrückt zu testen und eine flut an
falschen ergebnissen in der inzidenz
statistik eingeht bleiben wer den doktor
meine sammeln lärm wollen sie von der
spd dass dass sie das als erstes fordern
zeugt entweder von mangel sagt
expertisen oder mangelndem
demokratieverständnis sieht es zunächst
auch ohne zulassungsverfahren auf den
markt zu bringen ist das i-tüpfelchen
ihre wahnsinns kreation dieses selbst
das konzept darf nicht als weiteres
populistisches mitteln durch gepresst
werden
der langsam haben die menschen da
draußen die nase gestrichen voll
die wirkung die wir hier in deutschland
seien monaten erleben erinnert an eine
bananenrepublik lockt damit in
endlosschleife hysterische politiker
aber karl lauterbach und ein ministerium
innenministerium das die forschung
korrumpiert und politische maßnahmen
umzusetzen
meine damen und herren orwells
überwachungsstaat aus dem buch 1984 wird
2020 teilweise zur realität
sowie 19 beschäftigt uns nun seit über
einem jahr und von den schnelltest für
zuhause erhoffen sich viele menschen
mehr normalität
genau das will die kfd auch jedoch mit
verstand logik bevor wir das land mit
unsicheren schnelltest fluten müssen wir
die wurzel allen übels abschaffen
das heißt dass die willkürlichen und
sich ständig ändernden inzidenz stellen
streichen und die ausrichtung der
politischen maßnahmen an diesen ein für
alle mal beenden
vielen dank der bundestag diskutiert
über ein antrag der fdp coruna
selbsttests schneller einfacher freier
und der nächste redner ist ein ritter
dem man gar nicht so oft hier im
deutschen bundestag reden hört nämlich
lars klingbeil
er ist die generalsekretär der spd
das ist der kollege lars klingbeil von
spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ein dank an die fdp dass wir ein sehr
zentrales thema gerade doch in der
öffentlichkeit dass wir das hier mitten
im parlament diskutieren es ist gut dass
wir uns dafür zeit nehmen und sich vom
letzten redebeitrag abgesehen finde ich
auch ist das eine sehr konstruktive
debatte eine die wir mitten im parlament
führen sollten dafür ein großer dank
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zwölf
monate kämpfen wir als land als welt nun
gegen das corona virus zwölf monate die
uns als gesellschaft gefordert haben die
uns verändert haben die unseren alltag
radikal verändert haben gewohnheiten
verändern
außergewöhnliche harte und
herausfordernde zeiten und auch wenn wir
glaube ich gerade alle die korona
müdigkeit spüren macht es an solchen
tagen auch sinn sich bewusst zu machen
was wir alles in diesem land erlebt
haben auf das wir stolz sein können
wir haben in den letzten monaten erlebt
wie die solidarität im land gewachsen
ist wie man sich gegenseitig kümmert wie
man sich beschützt wie man das in der
nachbarschaft auch erlebt selbst in
meinem wahlkreis erlebt dass
sportvereine auf einmal einkaufshilfen
organisieren dass bürgerbusse
lebensmittel ausliefern das
hilfsorganisation innerhalb kürzester
zeit in der lage sind impfzentren
einzurichten
und jetzt gerade in diesen tagen können
wir alle in unseren wahlkreisen erleben
dass es freiwillige sind die fahrdienste
in diese impfzentren organisieren das
alles zeigt also die menschen sind
solidarisch sind füreinander da wir
können uns aufeinander verlassen und ich
finde dass gerade eine solche debatte
hier im parlament auch ein ereignis ist
an dem wir als parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier danke sagen sollten dann
alle die die uns geholfen haben in den
letzten zwölf monaten das land durch
eine schwierige zeit zu bringen also ein
großer dank an alle
wir wollten wir sehen also nach zwölf
monaten die solidarität ist ungebrochen
aber in der tat auch ich spüre dass die
korona müdigkeit zunimmt und dass so
manchem die puste ausgeht
die belastungen sind für alle spürbar
die erzieherin und lehrer die sich um
die kinder und jugendlichen kümmern
wollen die da sein wollen sie sich aber
selbst auch gedanken um ihre gesundheit
noch die pflegekraft dieser zwölf
monaten alles gibt um menschenleben zu
schützen
der gastronom der sich an alle regeln
gehalten hat der schutzkonzepte
aufgestellt hat und trotzdem seit
november keine kunden mehr bedienen kann
oder die künstlerin die seit einem jahr
die bühne schmerzlich vermisst alle
diese menschen kennt wir doch aus
unseren wahlkreisen alle diese menschen
halten sich an die regeln
alle diese menschen tragen politische
entscheidung aus diesem parlament oder
aus anderen runden mit und alle diese
menschen haben eine klare erwartung an
die politik dass wir alles geben dass
wir 24 stunden am tag uns darum kümmern
dass wir gut durch diese pandemie kommt
dass wir an wegen aus dieser pandemie
arbeiten ich will das hier sagen ich
habe einen großen respekt vor all denen
die verantwortung tragen in der
bundesregierung in den landesregierung
aber es ist nicht die zeit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für
selbstdarstellung von ministerinnen und
minister
es ist die zeit in der hart gearbeitet
werden muss in der regierung die
menschen wollen kein jubel die wollen
keine platten durchhalteparolen die
wollen keine aufgesetzten versprechen
und sie wollen erst recht keine
enttäuschung
die menschen wollen sehen dass die
politik hat für sie arbeitet und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist die
pflicht die wir auch hier im parlament
gemeinsam haben und es geht jetzt darum
öffnungs perspektiven zu schaffen klar
nachvollziehbare kriterien anhand gehen
dann auch klar wird wie es besser wird
und wie wir rauskommen aus dieser krise
das ist die erwartung die wir alle für
die nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben und
wir müssen auch über den weg dahin rät
und der weg lautet impfen testen und
kontakte nachverfolgen
ich finde gut dass wir über das testen
reden und testen
ist für mich ein teil der strategie wenn
es nicht um den locker und gehen soll
ich sage ihnen ganz klar der lok da und
ist nicht der weg aus dieser krise der
weg aus der krise ist impfen testen und
kontakte nachverfolgen und wir erleben
doch in diesen tagen alle das ist kluge
konzepte gibt da sind die gastronomen
die mit testen kluge ideen auf den weg
bringen wie man restaurants wieder
öffnen kann da sind diejenigen aus dem
bereich der kultur die kluge konzepte
haben die schulen und kitas testen
gehört zum öffnen mit dazu da sind wir
uns doch einig wir können grundrechte
zurückgeben wenn stärker getestet wird
und wie bei ihren spanisch will das hier
sagen es ist deswegen gut dass es beim
testen jetzt endlich vorangeht bei den
schnelltest und bei den selbsttest
das ist eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe die
wir gemeinsam stemmen müssen als politik
egal ob regierung opposition landbund
wir müssen das gemeinsam stemmen weil es
der weg raus ist aus dieser pandemie
aber ich sage ihnen auch lieber jens
spahn
ich sage ihnen auch lieber jens spahn
millionen menschen in diesem land schaut
auf sie
millionen menschen haben die hoffnung
dass es besser wird und wenn sie dann
dinge per twitter versprechen die sie
nicht halten können dann zerstört dass
das vertrauen in politik insgesamt und
das darf nicht sein
und ich will auch etwas sagen zu einem
zweiten thema das uns aus dieser
pandemie raus für das impfen
über monate haben wir den menschen
gesagt wenn der impfstoff da ist dann
ist das die wende das ist das licht am
ende des tunnels und wir merken gerade
wie wir den anschluss verlieren
die kritik von anfang des jahres will
ich sagen hat geholfen dass wir besser
geworden sind
aber jetzt dreht sich die debatte jetzt
können wir morgens in den zeitungen
lesen dass impfdosen nicht verimpft
werden
wir haben eine gute infrastruktur und zu
wenig impfstoff und das dreht sich jetzt
gerade das hört man in vielen gesprächen
in ein paar wochen werden wir zu viel
impfstoff haben und keine
infrastrukturen der das verimpft werden
kann
aber wollen wir nicht vorausschauend
politik machen ist es nicht jetzt
aufgabe des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums die länder
und die bundeswehr und die
hilfsorganisation an einen tisch zu
holen und zu gucken wie machen
drei länder dass die 24 stunden sieben
tage die woche impfen brauchen wenig
diesen kraft liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist doch das was die
menschen von uns erwarten dass wir es
können keine öffnungszeiten keine natur
und kein wochenende und wenn das stimmt
was ich vorhin gesagt habe dass so viele
menschen von uns erwarten dass wir es
besser machen dann muss das doch der
geist sein denn der bundesregierung und
auch in diesem haus herrscht wir wollen
es besser machen weil wir den anspruch
haben das land vernünftig durch diese
pandemie durchzubringen
herzlichen dank und kollegen bei der die
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
fdp.die abgeordnete christine
aschenberg-dugnus sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
jahr anzugehen schnelltests sind ein
wichtiger baustein in der pandemie
bekämpfung vor allem bei den immer noch
herrschenden impfstoffmangel und dem
sich ausbreitenden virusvarianten umso
schlimmer ist dass herr minister sparen
dass sie ihr versprechen ab dem ersten
märz allen bürgerinnen und bürgern
kostenlose schnelltests zur verfügung zu
stellen dass das nicht gehalten wurde
wie haben sie damals sehr gelobt dafür
wir haben uns darauf gefreut wie alle
bürgerinnen und bürger
und jetzt hat die kanzlerin sich
eingeschaltet und ihre vorlage
einkassiert wissen sie mir ist es egal
ob sie da ein zwist mit der
bundeskanzlerin aus schächten oder nicht
aber wenn es darum geht dass bildung das
kunst das kultur das gastronomie das
sport damit verhindert wird dann trifft
es die gesamte bevölkerung und das
können wir nicht akzeptieren meine damen
und herren und ihr ganzes hin und her
bewirkt wieder einmal einen massiven
vertrauensverlust in der bevölkerung und
das
wir in der jetzigen situation überhaupt
nicht gebrauchen das sagen übrigens
nicht nur wir als fdp fraktion sondern
auch professor da braucht der ehemalige
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrates auf
denen wir doch immer so gerne hören
meine damen und herren wir fordern sie
mit unserem antrag auf gemeinsam mit den
ländern einen stufenplan auszuarbeiten
und dabei antigen schnelltests zur
selbstanwendung zu integrieren
wir haben übrigens vor zwei wochen auch
schon einen bundesweiten stufenplan
eingebracht hier vorgelegt können sie
gerne nachlesen und auch übernehmen
genauso wie den jetzt vorliegenden
antrag das würde zumindest schneller
gehen denn wieder einmal sind wochen
vergangen wo nichts passiert ist ich
höre hier immer nur was nicht geht sagen
sie doch endlich mal was geht das würde
perspektiven für die bevölkerung
schaffen meine damen und herren
österreich und dänemark haben es
vorgemacht und uns einen schwund und
schnelltest als einen weg aus dem lock
down eingeführt warum läuft das
eigentlich bei uns nicht so wir könnten
das bei allen schülerinnen und schülern
vor der schule machen das würde
sicherheit geben und das würde auch den
alltag der menschen erleichtern
schnelltests bieten sicherheit im alltag
wir können damit ganz konkrete
situationen absichern schnelltest vor
einer kulturveranstaltung schnelltest
vor einem restaurant besuch vor einer
sportveranstaltung oder wie gesagt der
tägliche selbst test in schule und kita
meine damen und herren so lange wir noch
nicht ausreichend impfstoff zur
verfügung haben ist dies der einzige weg
wie wir gefahrlos vorsichtige schritte
hin zu mehr freiheit ermöglichen und das
ist doch das was wir alle wollen was
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger wollen
meine damen und herren wir wollen den
menschen perspektiven bieten und herr
minister sie haben doch gestern selbst
im ausschuss gesagt dass wir genügend
selbsttests haben dass genügend test
vorhanden sind und auch umgeht dass die
strukturen da sind um diese
durchzuführen ja worauf warten wir denn
dann noch meine damen und herren liefern
sie endlich und haben sie an ihrer seite
aber dann müssen sie ihre versprechungen
auch einhalten vielen dank meine damen
und herren ja entspannt kriegs hier
ordentlich mit er hatte es angekündigt
die bundeskanzlerin hat das ganze
zurückgezogen seit gestern oder
vorgestern sind die tests zugelassen
wann sie kommen das ist noch die frage
am dritten märz jedenfalls sollen die
schnelltests in die strategie mit
eingearbeitet werden das hat die
bundeskanzlerin gesagt und er gestern
auch bei der befragung hier vor dem
hohen hause alexander kraus jetzt für
die cdu/csu sie machen es uns leichter
dass wir durch diese pandemie
durchkommen sie sind aber kein
allheilmittel
also wenn ich meine vorrednerin jetzt
gehört habe so nach dem motto man bindet
mal die schnellste es an und dann kommt
man aus dem lock daraus ist so einfach
ist die welt leider nicht weil sie haben
es gesagt aber keine frage
selbst test- und schnell kerstin
meilenstein bürger weiter vorankommen
ich hoffe es uns gelingt gerade in
schulen und kitas diese tests
einzusetzen das kann das
infektionsrisiko deutlich senken es lebt
darauf vom mitmachen
in dem bundesland wo ich herkomme
sachsen hat man schnell tests angeboten
in den schulen freiwillig für die
schüler ein drittel haben sie nur
benutzt haben diese quoten müssen gehör
bringen
es muss selbstverständlich sein dass man
sagt man macht ein schnelltest mit oder
vielleicht sogar selbst fest weil er
eben einfacher ist und vielleicht manche
ängste nimmt und es bleibt dabei die
grundregeln die wir aufgestellt haben
abstand halten
händewaschen alltags masken tragen
lüften die korona benutzen
das müssen wir weiterhin beibehalten zu
glauben dass man das vernachlässigen
kann das wird schiefgehen
und natürlich keine frage wir müssen
auch beim thema impfen vorankommen weil
das der größte schritt ist der uns hilft
gut durch diese pandemie durchzukommen
stellte es seit gestern zugelassen
dürfen sich zu einer trügerischen
sicherheit führen zu einer
scheinsicherheit
darauf weist das robert koch-institut ja
richtigerweise hin denn sie haben eine
geringere sensitivität sie sind also
weniger genau als ein pcr test sind also
keine absolut sichere methode und sie
leben davon dass sie sachgerecht
angewendet werden
es bringt wenig wenn man einen test
anwendet das aber nicht richtig macht
und damit dann auch kein
aussagekräftiges ergebnis kriegt und
wichtig ist dann wenn ein positives
gestatten sie dazwischen frage
gestritten
herr kollege sie haben gerade zu recht
darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich für
die schnecke ist es notwendig ist dass
sie auch richtig angewandt werden
und der kollege hat das ja auch schon
beschrieben gehabt und deswegen frage
ich sie inwieweit die bundesregierung
eine breite aufklärungskampagne über
sinn zweck und anwendungsbereiche der
schnelltests vorbereitet hat und mit der
zulassung jetzt auch sofort loslegen
kann damit die menschen zum beispiel
jeden zweiten zweimal in der woche
morgens testen können hier entstand
feststellen können sich aber auch dann
wissen erstens wie man es richtig macht
und zweitens wie man sich verhält wenn
man das ergebnis vorzulegen hat der
vielen dank die frage ist sehr wichtig
ist und ich glaube da führt auch nochmal
zu dem fdp-antrag den wir gehört haben
also klar ist ich finde es macht wenig
sinn da man eine test macht die man sich
irgendwo kauft oder irgendwo besorgt und
auf der anderen seite soll dann irgendwo
in der zeitung eine anzeige geschaltet
werden wie das funktioniert sondern
logisch ist doch wenn man einen testkauf
dass dort eine packungsbeilage dabei ist
bei einem selbsttest wo ich genau sehen
kann wie der funktioniert
und deswegen ist es auch wichtig liebe
kollegen von der fdp dass man nicht nur
sagt die sollen mal alle dinge tests auf
den markt bringen und dann gucken wir
mal was passiert sondern dass man vorher
schaut ist der test sinnvoll und gut und
ist dann eine gebrauchsanweisung dabei
mit der man irgendetwas anfangen kann
deswegen ist dieser testdurchlauf dass
mein testet ob der test gut ist so enorm
wichtig dass ich wieder zurück kommen
also wir werden diese selbsttests haben
es ist davon auszugehen dass bei 0,89
prozent der tests ein positives ergebnis
vorliegt und dann ist es wichtig dass
diesen test dann nachgegangen wird dass
es dann einen pcr-test gibt dass das
auch in der gebrauchsanweisung steht wie
man wo zu gehen hat wenn das ergebnis
positiv ist dass wir das machen und wir
haben in deutschland eine sehr sehr gute
kapazität aufgebaut was die labore
betrifft haben die möglichkeit in
deutschland 2,4 millionen pcr tests
durchzuführen als er eine enorme
leistung
sehr leistungsfähige labore darauf
können wir stolz sein dass wir so eine
infrastruktur haben
es ist ja ein bereich der immer mal im
schatten steht weil ein labor arzt oder
die labormitarbeiter insgesamt die sieht
man nicht aber wir haben dort wirklich
gerade auch was dann das nachverfolgen
betrifft wenn wir die folgen
sequenzierung sehen um herauszubekommen
und welche virusvarianten handelt es
sich zum beispiel
dort haben wir sehr gute labore und
kapazitäten darauf können wir stolz sein
und das ist gut so meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ich möchte noch ganz
kurz auf das thema impfen nochmal
eingeben
weil das auch der kollege klingbeil
angesprochen hat also keine frage wir
werden jetzt in der zeit rein kommen wo
die kapazitäten die die bundesländer
jahr bereitgestellt haben für das impfen
was sie für die impfzentren zuständig
sind nicht reichen werden und die
impfstoffe aufzunehmen die zur verfügung
stehen werden also eine positive
entwicklung war es mehr impfstoffe gibt
das ist ja schön und gut
und jetzt müssen wir uns gedanken machen
wie kann man die eben zentren
leistungsfähiger machen und auf der
anderen seite ist das richtig was der
minister auch gesagt hat dass wir
schauen müssen wenn wir drei bis fünf
millionen impfdosen haben pro woche wie
kümmern die hausarztpraxen einbinden
yanar in der folgesaison kein problem
gehabt ohne dass uns das irgendwie
aufgefallen heißt das 14 millionen
impfdosen im bereich der krippe einfach
mal so vernünftigen sind und dieses jahr
vielleicht um dieser saison vielleicht
über 20 millionen
also wir sehen wir haben dort einen
hohen leistungsfähiges system in den
hausarztpraxen was auch schneller gehe
was auch schneller geht denn der
hausarzt der muss sich im gegensatz zu
dem arzt ins zentrum nicht erst
anschauen was ist das für ein patient
was hat er dafür
vorerkrankungen und so weiter weil das
schön weiß und damit wesentlich
schneller vorankommen und wenn es
gelingt dass man sagt wir machen ein
zwei tage in der woche in der
hausarztpraxis einen impftag dann
kümmert das wunderschön die große menge
auch an patienten in diesen zwei tagen
durchziehen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
vielen herzlichen dank an das
bundesgesundheitsministerium und hat
alle die bei uns im gesundheitswesen
arbeiten ihr leistet hervorragendes
damit wir gut durch diese pandemie
durchgang auch wenn es viel prügel gibt
wenn ich an der stelle auch sagen er
macht wirklich einen tollen job und
macht bitte weiter so ich bin mir sicher
dass wir gut durch diese pandemie
durchkommen werden vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank
jetzt der letzte redner zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt der kollege erwin
rüddel cdu
[Applaus]
der letzte redner in dieser debatte ist
der vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses erwin redl
gestatten sie mir dass ich zu beginn
meiner rede einen satz verwende für die
rede des kollegen klingbeil
er hat eine schwierige position zu
bekleiden regierende opposition ist
etwas was unsere verfassung nicht kennt
aber er muss diese rolle ausüben was
mich nur wundern was nicht nur wundert
ist dass er hier am pult steht und als
ihn sozusagen für die gesundheitspolitik
sich erklärt dass wir mehr öffnungen
brauchen und sein spd gesundheitsexperte
karl lauterbach in jeder talkshow und
bei jeder gelegenheit davor waren und
ich glaube liebe freunde von der spd
sie müssen mal ihre position klären sind
sie für mehr öffnungen oder sind sie
gegen neueröffnungen und ich wundere
mich permanent warum ihr
gesundheitsexperte hier im bundestag
nicht reden darf
zu diesem thema es ist richtig und
wichtig dass jens spahn den weg
beschritten hat flächendeckenden einsatz
von schnelltests das ist ein wichtiger
baustein aber ein baustein den es auch
schon seit vielen monaten gibt der weg
aus der grund aus dem corona lockdown
geht über drei instrumente impfen testen
und weiterer strikte einhaltung von
schutz und hygienemaßnahmen gratis
schnelltests als angebot für alle bürger
durchgeführt von geschultem personal und
perspektivisch auch eigenen test für
jedermann direkt für zuhause und
öffnungs strategien sind folglich
zentraler bestandteil der pandemie
eindämmen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat die
geänderte test verordnung für den ersten
märz fertig gestellt und vom
bundesfinanzministerium auch die
entsprechende finanzierungszusage halten
wenn sich nun im sogenannten corona
kabinett herausstellt dass es angesichts
unterschiedlichster planungen und
öffnung strategien der bundesländer noch
klärungsbedarf mit blick auf diverse
fragen der organisation und der
vorhandenen kapazitäten gibt so kann ich
wegen der verschiebung vom ersten märz
auf den dritten märz nicht recht
nachvollziehen warum dies ein grund sein
soll
für eine neuerliche überflüssige
dramatisierung der lage
bei denn bei diesen beratungen am
dritten märz wird es genau darum gehen
die schnell und eigenen tests in eine
gesamtstrategie aus impfen testen und
schutzmaßnahmen einzubetten die unserem
land endlich wirksame öffnungs
perspektiven erlauben werden insofern
geschieht genau das was die sp fdp
tschuldigung die fdp fraktion mit ihrem
antrag fordert mehr testen für öffnungs
strategien
meine damen und herren dabei müssen wir
uns allerdings im klaren darüber sein
dass ist von mehreren rednern gesagt
worden aber ich halte es für
ausgesprochen wichtig dass schnell und
insbesondere eigenen test auch
trügerische sicherheit vermitteln können
fehler sind nicht auszuschließen und die
ergebnisse werden immer nur eine
momentaufnahme sein
das heißt nicht dass was nicht machen
sollen sondern wir sollten es machen in
großer verantwortung gestatten sie mir
noch zwei anmerkungen einmal an die
adresse der bundesländer die ständig
neue forderungen in richtung lockerungen
kommunizieren aber bei der umsetzung
konkreter maßnahmen fast immer auf den
bund zahlen
es steht den ländern doch frei in
eigener verantwortung zu handeln und
beispielsweise mit blick auf schulen und
kitas und anderen einrichtungen im
großen stil durch zu testen
es ist auf die dauer einfach ermüdend
wenn in den ländern einerseits konkret
der lockdown beschlossen wird und dann
mit blick auf das publikum ständig mit
öffnung und und lockerungen gewunken
wird aber konkret wenig oder nichts
passiert außerdem schon
gewohnheitsmäßigen ruf nach frischem
geld vom bund
meine letzte bemerkung betrifft das
impfen ja wir haben momentan einen
engpass aber wir können ab sofort
erzieherinnen und lehrkräfte in kitas
grund und förderschulen impfen und ich
würde mir wünschen obwohl ich mir
wünschte dass wir mehr impfstoffe hätten
aber wir wussten das schon im letzten
jahr dass das diesmal dieses erste
quartal schwierig sein wird aber ich
würde mir wünschen dass die länder in
der lage sind den impfstoff den wir zur
verfügung stellen dann auch zügig zu
verkaufen und hier versagen manche
länder dazu gehört auch mein eigenes
bundesland in rheinland-pfalz aber ich
höre dass auch von niedersachsen und
anderen
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir diese
pandemie im sommer überwunden haben wir
mehr freiheiten haben und wir werden in
den im prozess eine große dynamik
bekommen wenn die hausärzte einsteigen
werden die betriebsärzte ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir die pandemie im
sommer überwunden haben vielen dank
vielen dank
wenn wirklich schlüssige aussprache zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt in der
fraktion l wird überweisung der vorlage
aufdruck 26 8 78 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
dass es nicht der fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen